fabrique des glaces et des sorbets
durant la saison estivale
et puis là là on va commencer à
fabriquer des desserts glacés pour pour
les fêtes
metro france à un grossiste 'b to b' qui
a pour client à 400 mille professionnels
indépendants français de la restauration
et des métiers de bouche
[Musique]
alter elle s'étend glaciers local des
yvelines avec lequel on a travaillé qui
d'abord à était client chez nous
puisqu'il s'est fourni en matières
premières chez nous avant de devenir
ensuite fournisseurs on a connu en août
2019 un incendie qui a détruit
l'ensemble de notre ancien laboratoire
de production notre ancienne fabrique de
glace quand on a vu ça dans le journal
le parisien on l'a tout simplement
proposé à elle perd elle de les loger
dans un bâtiment qu'on a à côté
quel ancien bâtiment des produits
d'équipement le magasin métro et notre
bailleur puisque c'est eux qui nous qui
nous loue le bâtiment dans lequel on
fabrique tous les journaux glace
cette aide a été elle s'est faite
naturellement en fait tout simplement
parce que ben voilà on commercialisent
leurs produits ils sont nice aussi chez
nous donc c'est tout naturellement qu'on
s'est rapproché d'eux pour leur proposer
une solution
[Musique]
c'est que métro et un vrai partenaire
pour pour les restaurateurs est donc
c'est vraiment un billet un billet qu'on
veut utiliser pour se faire connaître et
pour augmenter notre chiffre d'affaires
auprès des restaurateurs de la région
les restaurateurs alors un petit peu
moins cette année due à la crise du coc
ville mais représente à peu près 20%
notre chiffre d'affaires le reste est
fait en grande distribution et l'intérêt
pour le magasin métro dans cette
collaboration il est double puisque ça
permet aussi aux collaborateurs de
s'immerger de voir le fonctionnement
d'un fournisseur local notamment glacier
de rencontrer aussi d'autres partenaires
locaux
[Musique]
on a pour ambition pour le coup avec
métro d'aller prospecter de nouveaux
clients ensemble ou on pourrait imaginer
un partenariat ou métro
et nous propose aurions une offre glace
clé en main pour la saison d'été aux
restaurateurs
avec peut-être un frigo des petits pots
à déguster en smoking pour renforcer le
partenariat existant avec alter elle est
ce qu'on a décidé de faire avec pierre
basset de mutualiser nos forces c'est à
dire que moi je possède des clients sur
sur la zone que je connais bien c'est la
force de métro on connaît bien nos
clients est lui par contre comme il se
fournit essentiellement aux produits
locaux dans la zone mais l'idée c'est de
mutualiser nos forces et de pouvoir
référencer un maximum de producteurs et
de et de fournisseurs locaux